j'aperçois enfin le quatrième membre du
corps diplomatique goerges et bonjour
boulogne france bleu goerges et france
ça va pas trop la gerbe au nom ça va
mais dans la famille on a le pied marin
d'après faut dire qu'elle a un sacré
boulot là pour recréer une sensation de
gravité dans le module module tenue
d'astronautes
bienvenue dans la station spatiale jean
vilar cinq humains doivent écrire une
pièce à transmettre à toute forme de vie
ouais on est en train de le perdre on va
abréger leur ça a toujours été un rien
de d'établir une forme de communication
d'ailleurs un archéologue qui tangue
chauny un artefact de nature artistique
se réjouit parce qu'il ya énormément de
choses encoder là dedans une toile sandy
autant sur son époque que peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui à une caméra ou un iphone
j'étais vraiment les mystères d'une
forme de vie serait peut-être déjà
totalement avec ses parents une mission
qui sera un échec total mais corps
diplomatique s'interroge en fait sur le
temps celui de chaque jour celui de la
création
que se passera-t-il si on supprimait la
valeur tant dans le travail artistique
c'est plus de deadline s'il ya plus de
premières s'y ajuste un processus qui ne
cesse jamais d'avoir lieu et qui a une
écriture par un autre qu'est ce que ça
donne moi la réponse on la connaît c'est
mauvaise idée il faut qu'il y ait une
première et footing deadline il faut
qu'il ya un moment où les choses se fige
des personnages un peu crétin une bonne
dose d'humour pour déclencher rire et
réflexions comme si les monty python
rencontre et beckett your gillot est
comme un trou dans cette fuite
cet état combien de doigts 10 eh ben ça
fait quand même pas mal de possibilités
ça non